welcome to this video playing practice
practice from the US 24 14 rating and
yeah let's let's let's play something
else the color one of those openings
that you can play without much
theoretical knowledge okay yes still I
like to play as ambitious as possible
yeah now Bishop b5 as a threat like
needs to react to that
this some setup that he choses in fact
quite risky in this particular line
let's see
you know even even Queen edge try it as
a move let's let's just go ahead here
yeah if you place g6 she didn't then
there were interesting ideas even
sacrificing what's possible okay i want
to i want to get in look see one quickly
you gaining this temple
yeah still roop see one why why not what
you see can you play some sort of crazy
Queen sacrifice where
yeah man this is a this is tricky for
black yes but he still cannot cancel due
to the meydan h7 so the question is
right may just just take cover just open
open the position I need to be coo again
and he really has got limited options
you can in various ways try to win a
pawn now on e5 and so on so on but this
is this is really dangerous okay I don't
have rupee one unfortunately
hmm yeah interesting
m flag rook a to c 1 the sir is a bit
slow and he's got age 6 this is really a
move that I need to to look at maybe I
must must mix the bishop with rookie
three
look III would be three and book you
want something like that but still
there's this h6 move okay not the most
powerful move freely okay maybe this
wasn't so convincing I mean it still
feels like a lie quite an has something
but it's not apparent that black should
instantly lose which I really have
expected to be okay yeah now you can
even castle
yeah and I have a week back rank this is
also problem there should be four for
instance is answered by 94 yeah I need
to make sure that I'm not mated on the
background and give me some subspace mh4
is useful anyway it's not this position
is still interesting it's not like I'm
directly lost or something like that 94
maybe you can play you for
hmm is it that some some way to again I
didn't come down on time
you can just take a two to be honest
yeah I can just play for
like it's just a bone of him I have have
checked some activity not enough
probably but some activity or maybe in
queen bee 8 and t4 hangs so it's not so
easy nobody can take care hi morning
this is not really threatening much of a
non-threatening create this is check
check check check check goddamn check
check Jeremy's going to manage that
white haha yeah wow this is a really bad
streak of games I mean this is this
opening is just plain bad for black and
I fail to punish it so this don't really
think this can be you can be bad up to
now it's probably okay but I need to do
something else here it seems that after
Knight c3 he can really grab all this
and get away with it money to him to
need to improve him now the computer
wants to take on c6 on player and all
9292 was an interesting way yeah it's a
it's not so easy to play with limited
time we have so many options and how to
get to grips with all of them
this is what the comp is giving with the
very young very strong compensation yeah
it's giving wider clear cheer the dump
very difficult to do to judge I mean 93
looks perfectly logical to me and plenty
i have compensation but I didn't really
didn't really find a convincing way to
play okay here we should be three wines
why this is almost winning v6 hangs and
thus we should reform yeah the computer
gives vital very big edge here yeah well
that's it's it's it's tricky that's
really tricky and now takes and Bishop
before yeah maybe maybe that one this
looks quite convincing to be honest yeah
I missed many good opportunities in this
game that's quite clear yeah and this is
a very good position I just attacked b6
if you place this group c 70 where do
you go with this unlucky night yeah
that's excellent for light and easy to
play okay I went here you sometimes
don't consider the Queen trade if your
material down that this is the right way
to go yeah and here i mean i have some
vague compensation but not not enough
around here i thought it was source
already quite okay but check check
yeah okay Queen a3 was I forgot that
this is a check Queen d6 this was
directly going into the lost end game
yeah it's a it's tricky tricky to play
and I'd lost I missed many good chances
the thing that you need to note from a
black point of view that this is really
a very risky way to play this early
opening up of the center it's um it's a
very very risky alright thanks for
watching